hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu
and this is your reminder that i watch
one episode at a time and write the
review for each episode individually
that's about to become somewhat relevant
because some of the assumptions i made
in episode 116
didn't bear out in 117 and i'm sad about
it but i don't want to change my
thoughts on it because they're still
valid none of this was funny i'm afraid
so here's a selection of stupid noises
for your enjoyment
whoa let's get into it episode 116 might
be my favorite episode of the series so
far
we checked in with everyone else briefly
but that's exactly how i think it needed
to be
we needed to know exactly what was
happening and reminded what was
happening but we also needed to have as
much time as possible for the stillness
and silence required
for what transpired gone this episode
got given the chance to change and be
more than he is as a person
not as a combatant but as a person and
he chose not to i've never seen gone be
so clear characters in this episode and
i'm really glad we could work up to this
point
not only was it the clearest we've seen
gone but it's the first time i think
after all my pontificating on kilwa last
week that kilwa has actually seen
gone for exactly who and what he is when
we look at ikalgo his motivations are
pure his reasoning is clear and you can
see that he values friendship
and his friends and he treats them
nicely gone has shown that he's the
polar opposite to that and it's a really
interesting metaphor that icalgo's often
hidden behind another face
while gone was the one truly hidden away
this episode
kilwa stopped being of use to god in
fact that's not quite accurate this
episode
gone realized he had a conscience he'd
never had one before and he wasn't sure
where he picked it up from
and i don't think he likes it because he
got rid of it or at least you know made
it feel bad
if kilwa hadn't told gon how pito would
be of use to him pito
and kamugi would be dead now as
potentially would kilwa for daring to
try to get in his way
i feel somewhat vindicated about my
questioning of kite mentions in the last
episode i noted then that how we talk
about things and people tend to
indicate how we feel about them and that
the fact that no one
had mentioned kite at all even gone
spoke to doubt that any of this was
still about him
and i was right none of this is about
kite anymore it wasn't until kiwa
reminded gone that maybe it should be
or that it could be the absence of
friendship in that room will stay with
me for some time
the image of the softly lit room with
the two shadows is very much how i'm
reading that metaphorically and i think
it's a beautiful way to show that there
in that room were two people who knew
nothing about each other briefly jumping
to pito
we learned a lot from the way they
talked and what they did this episode
about how they feel about the king and
how they felt things were going
pito obviously feels very different
pitot obviously feels very differently
to moth boy sheila perth about the
changes that have occurred to the king
rather than being traitorous they've
gone in the other direction they've
softened they see behaviors that are
coming into play that'll destroy the
king
if kamugi dies and destroy any chance of
the whole world surviving potentially
what we got to see in this
was more empathy in the monsters gone
desperately wants to fight
than in gone and the fact that pito
decided to try telling the truth tells
us that not only do they
truly believe in what's happening but
that they truly believe
they were talking to a human in all the
senses of the word but there was no
humanity in gone this episode and all
the art all the shifts between style the
faded eyes the rough emptiness the rage
the tears
all of it looked beautiful and cold and
impulsive
and empty and we got so many eyes and so
many different iterations that i just
kind of
disconnected from gone i mean i've
always been
quite disconnected but on a new level
not only was there the lack of humanity
but
the lack of human rights hewa noted
their hands on the ground
gone clearly saw the hands on the ground
and his energy dropped back briefly
only for him to say he didn't care so he
knew what it meant or he could
interpret or infer what it meant and he
didn't
care and let's talk about the function
of kiwa for a moment killa in all of
this was there to be a fantastic
reminder that gohan's age has nothing to
do with his decision-making right now
kilwa saw the situation he always saw
that gone was in distress he knew there
was more
happening than met the i and he as much
as gone has already made friends with
one of the ants so it's not even as
though we can use
generalized prejudice as an excuse here
gone wanted revenge because something
was taken gone wants revenge because his
toy is broke and has been turned into
someone else's toy and he will not allow
anyone else to puppet something that's
his when pito managed to halt kilauea
enough that kielwa
an assassin by trade stopped to assess
and question the fairness of the
situation and raise concerns about his
own humanity it made clear how little
gone
actually cares about human life or lie
his concern
is him why say his name gone freaks
because it's a source of pride
because when he kills pito he wants pito
to know that he is stronger and worthy
but pito was already afraid for someone
else
something gone didn't even stop to
consider because how could he
and that's why kiel was gone because
kilwa saw all those things in this
moment one thing kilwa has
is bucket loads of perception he's been
blinded this whole time because
gone called him a friend and i'm really
hoping that ends now
when kilauea was lying in a pool of his
own blood it wasn't gone who saved gon
didn't know where he was i get it like
i truly get it but it wasn't gone who
saved him and that's important in this
context
when he explained to ikalgo how his
friendship works he repeated the
experiences he's had in friendship that
came from gone
when he calgo said thang it was the
first time it had happened and that was
a revelation for him the episode is
called revenge and recovery
i'm hoping kilwa stays gone i'm hoping
kihua gets to live the life he deserves
with friends who deserve him while gone
seeks revenge
i hope kielba seeks recovery of his soul
let's look at episode 117 because
yeah as much as i was hoping that this
was the case it it's not episode 117
and it saddens me to find that actually
killah didn't just come to his senses
and leave he was tapped on the shoulder
by a helpful chameleon
in in a cute track suit as usual i'm
glad he left the situation because
it would have been more damaging for him
to have just watched
for an hour but still i was hoping he'd
left gone off his own steam
instead he's just been hurt by someone
who i doubt would apologize to him at
the end of it because he wouldn't even
see what he'd done
as hurtful coming from a family of
assassins and talking about
a family of assassins it's interesting
to me to see how much
more empathy and care they have and take
than a teenager i mean not for ants
which
by she too i mean you were just you were
being stupid and annoying toward the end
there and you know what i
i just like what what do you do like
what do you say
about like i i don't have i don't have
the words for cheating like i just kind
of
gesture and flail wildly in his
direction because
like dude chitu's end speaks to how
powerful the zoldick family actually is
given that the others struggled with him
and
before chitu's timely demise really now
read the room dude
kilwa's grandad seeming to feel remorse
for potentially killing someone who is
not the mark is fascinating because the
tone of the voice actor didn't seem
empty or frustrated
it seemed sad or you know remorseful i
guess
it didn't read to put it another way as
someone who is upset that they'd messed
up their job but as someone who goes out
of their way to make sure there's no
incidental casualties what i don't know
is whether he felt he was incidentally
killing someone who's not a mark through
his attack or
whether he thought he was killing
someone by letting gon go in to attack
pito oh
sure ultimately it seems he let his
grandson make that judgment
and told the father about how kilwa has
removed the needle which
kind of suggests it was put there to
protect kiewa from the impulsive and
stupid situations gone would get him
into and those situations are
admittedly horrendous kiwa has a natural
survival instinct but
gone doesn't so every time gone goes
somewhere kiel was there to drag him out
that needle is what dragged him out last
time the needle's gone no the needle's
not gone
like it's not the needle's been removed
yes meanwhile
i you know i i just just all of i i just
why am i this entire episode feels like
it was brought to us by the letter p
for pride it's just so unreasonable that
two men who have a task to do to protect
the world instead get mad because
someone treated them poorly like they
got mad
not even like they were treated poorly
not even physically
just treated them poorly and it's not
even poorly like he just
ignored them he did nothing and
apparently doing doing nothing is enough
like you're alive
huzzah you're alive against this thing
you know you can't fight and
and you can make a plan you have a task
at hand you have a job
do the job just do the job first gone
then these
dudes and cheat you and i just tantrums
aren't gonna help you
he humiliated me okay so that means you
can come back stronger and make him
regret having
done that in a smart way being
underestimated is an incredibly powerful
tool and
they just decided to throw it away you
literally
were running away from someone proven to
be more powerful than you
he lets you go because you're not the
focus and instead of coming up with a
better plan you decide i'll show him
i'll punch him twice which is admittedly
the most
i've managed to punch him so far that
rant out of the way i'm excited to see
what happens to soupy because he's
learned
he's not just soupy goop he's a powerful
sentient being with emotion of all the
characters
loyalty has been such an interesting
theme to return to repeatedly because
the characters have
different ways to engage the same ideas
in his one track mindedness our little
fey creature super yupi seems to
actually be the best of most worlds in
that he has the maturity to maintain his
one track mind in a way that protects in
the way he knows how wait
sentence no make senseie super up is
mature
but also one track minded and those two
things
help him out super up is also
empty-headed enough that he doesn't
think to check in on his boss but you
know i think we can forgive that as he
has the maturity to consider that
he needed to learn to manage his
emotions to have them best work for him
oh and i think
in that way it's pretty entertaining
that up is specifically noted not to be
human of course he would be able to
learn something about himself and apply
it effectively he's not concerned with
petty mortal issues like people making
him look the fool with an episode
dedicated to loyalty i think it's great
that we opened with gone throwing a
tantrum and kill our leaving
i think it's appropriate that she too
who had loyalty to no one and
nothing got crushed by the extreme
loyalty of this whole dicks and i think
the cat-like protection of pito
and the bulldog-like stubbornness of
yupi is telling of maturity and pureness
of thought that the humans just don't
seem to have
it's almost as though returning to the
animalistic tendencies of each
sub-creature gives them the roundness
that human society takes away and
isn't that intriguing while i ponder how
the development of ants is coming along
and have a well-earned meal
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
review click here here and here make
sure you're eating relaxing and
hydrating and i'll see you
next time